[MUSIC]
Let's talk about the sort
of perception of time.
And what the research shows us,
is that perception of experience time
is largely different by attention.
Time bothers us when we
pay attention to it.
And so the name of the game is
to give people distractions.
It makes time feel like
it went by quickly.
So, give your customers
something to do while waiting.
Compare an elevator ride, some companies
use music but usually they use irritating
music, but what if you play them the news
or some kind of interesting podcasts,
and then it almost becomes something,
it's distracting and fun to be waiting.
The other thing to do to manage time
is give people a sense of progress.
Okay the one thing we really
don't like is not knowing, right?
Not knowing when this
thing is going to end.
Actually, airlines used to be bad at this.
You had a boarding time but it was never
kind of clear exactly when it was.
And now they've shifted to telling you
exactly when the boarding time is, and
they even have a countdown telling you,
boarding is going to commence
in X amount of minutes.
The exact same amount of time where
you know kind of you have a sense of
progress versus you don't have a sense
of progress, feels completely different.
And so, Disney recognizes that it has
people waiting in lines for a ton of time.
And so what they do is they have these
kind of milepost where they say,
this is how much time you have left to go,
to give you a sense of what's happening.
Because we really don't like,
because we don't like to have
an experience where we don't have control.
So you want to give people
a sense of control.
What matters is not actual control, but
it's your sense of perceived control.
Do I feel like I'm controlling the time,
that's passing?
Or is this something else controlling
it and I have no control over.
Most of the time, customers
are engaging in these experiences and
they're not cynical.
When I go to Disney,
I know they're messing with my mind
with all the information about
the waiting time, but it still works.
You can have an objective time in
which something happened that's very
different than the subjective time,
in which something happened.
And so the question is, how do you manage
that subjective sense of elapsed time?
>> Understand How Consumers
"Experience" and
Rewire Your Approach To Product Strategy.
Learn more about
Innovative Product Leadership,
The Emerging Chief Product Officer.
[MUSIC]